please don't let me fall into the water
sailing on the outer other Lake in
Hamburg hello distressed cord Sandberg
is the gateway to the world and this is
the port the beautiful harbour the
beautiful I'll stow lake if you want to
sale here you can you have to have
something to do with water if you live
in hamburg at least you should i love
hamburg Hamburg's my pearl the most
beautiful city in Europe really since
this star tonight all [ __ ] yeah
le unnie Fernandez Ferrera is originally
from Brazil she came to Hamburg to study
and then settle down here as a hobby she
plays Brazilian music untied 96.0 a
local community radio station yet sphere
the VN now we will hear a beautiful song
to do with my home minister eyes oh I'm
so homesick
once all you girl
oh but I'm
deals
this
hi
I guess
the spa town of pasos de caldas known in
brazil for its sulfurous mineral springs
is where eliana was born once a year she
spent several weeks here visiting family
and friends pasos de caldas is a
tranquil place malanez mother lives in
the center Tarasco freshly grilled meat
in all variations is the traditional
dish at social gatherings elianas whole
family and all her old friends have come
to see her Familia billard the family
means a lot to me it's a very high
priority that's why every year I have to
fly back to Brazil if I can so I can
visit my mother so I can visit my
brothers this is very important for me
otherwise I couldn't live in Germany
Ella for you seemed a fitting today she
began she has always been different ever
since she was a child the first gift she
asked for was a wet suit she's very
active she always wants to be first she
found her world a bit too small for her
because she had big dreams Brazil might
be large but Germany had more to offer
it gave le unnie the chance to do
something which still costs an arm and a
leg in her home country to study with
the prospect of getting a job afterwards
love you son
the pie is the 12th parish school
yet sir but now I'm going to surprise my
mother at work let's go inside elman
these are young people from the 1st to
5th classes the fifth year and adults oh
cute baby this Catholic institution
focuses on adults in spite of compulsory
schooling illiteracy in Brazil still
runs at an average of ten percent
although here in the South it's probably
lower le Annie's mother is taught here
for the last 40 years my name would my
mother is a fighter really a very strong
woman and she has a saying those who
dare can achieve anything that i allus
like Donna sivaram who comes here to
learn how to read and write at the age
of 82 I'll kill for you I wanted to
apply for a savings account and the girl
told me that my daughter would have to
sign for me because I couldn't write my
own name so I decided to learn how but
my children thank God all went to school
and now I am learning it's never too
late you should never say no I'm too old
or I can't do this or that life goes on
the students affectionately call Ellie
Annie's mother Donna Anna her greatest
wish is that everyone should have a
chance in life and use it my remote the
advice fearless my mother knows how
important this is especially for a woman
because we live in different times and
women have to be strong and realize
their dreams
le unnie has a date with you la madera
her friend is a pharmacologist and works
at the health department in passos and
she's currently working on a very
interesting problem SI keystone this
business of natural radioactivity they
say it's very high amongst the highest
in the world is that truths every badge
yes especially at the more Hodor fijo
the Iron Mountain Nia car does which is
considered one of the world's most
radioactive areas for my thesis I'm
looking at whether this can cause cancer
as a pharmacologist of course I've got
the medical knowledge and I want to know
does the radiation cause cancer or does
it make cells resistant that's what
we're looking into and we also want to
disprove the urban legend that poses de
caldas causes cancer shared publicly
uncertainty even as a child I heard a
lot of stories about all Bourque side
and uranium at that time when they were
still mining in the aura Nia do brasil i
visited it with my school class
Elyon ease scientific curiosity is
aroused she's never been to the mahadeva
whole she wants to go there with EULA
the next day you'll endure colleague
Marco Antonio spontaneously decide to
take her the natural radiation here is
amongst the highest in the world you
can't see it smell it or taste it and
because you let has forgotten the Geiger
counter you can't hear it either
ridiculous a main quest the only sign is
the poisonous looking Oh curb and the
brown on the rock which indicates the
presence of iron oxide where yes when
Israel or the key a used to come over
the fabian here on the moho DeFeo the
radioactivity is of a very particular
sort killed a human arrow to talk it's
one of the few places in the world that
has thorium and rare earths therefore
there's still a lot to look into and
understand it's dangerous to stay here
there can't be any plantations livestock
or houses and if you are constantly
exposed to this natural radioactivity
not briefly like we are but if you stay
here for a long time my certificate then
you will get cancer so vicos that
consider the risk of cancer in such an
idyllic place it's still a contentious
issue but one thing is certain it all
depends on the dose
several kilometers further on is the
former uranium mining area that le unnie
visited with her class here they mined
uranium and extracted yellowcake highly
concentrated yellow uranium powder on a
large scale for over 20 years in that
we're too late we wanted to come earlier
come here my happen can we come in no
you have to make an appointment health
control paulinho go La Mina that's right
I was sleeping now you've woken me up
you're laughing aren't you otherwise
everything ok great you know hope she
might be able to get someone in charge
on the phone she wants to use her
connections I'm not sure where the
militia will allow it you know a tour of
the lakes because that's where they all
used to be you need to talk to Mauricio
just say Maurice he'll be nice I need
something from you my friend Melissa but
it's too late it's already six o'clock
the pair declined the security man's
kind offer of a glass of water the mine
was shut down for good in 1998 it was no
longer economically viable but Brazil
has plenty of other minds I need a screw
thought that was where the office was
and the production was there and behind
it the lake with the contaminated water
they also used to work at night you can
still see the remnants but everything
here is subject to national security or
do you think that's why the guys stopped
us we can't go where there's uranium
national security when thrown was
through enough enough mo sabi Vasya you
know if you look on Google Earth the
image is blurred LF UKISS you just can't
see anything possible so it looks quite
harmless
main Josh Man Man Man Man I think we
took a wrong turn I don't know we'll
have to see for now but I think we can
ask up their bond giacinta fazendo
comentario the northwest of brazil the
amazon basin the risk of taking a wrong
turn in this region is big there are
hardly any signs and GPS only works for
Anika layout here perfect oh my god the
song Bungie Anna don't look how it's
good that we soon realized we were on
the wrong road this is exciting Alfre
against it's also exciting because le
unnie finally sees a chance to find her
great-grandfather's former rubber farm
in Hakurei he was one of the first
rubber barons here in what was then
jungle but there's precious little
jungle left today this in song seemed
weird pretty shocked at the situation
here dalaga here this reactance very
quiet we see very little forest and
we've even seen sugar cane fields in an
area where they shouldn't be eamonn
sorry don't mess with them yo and then
it's called bioethanol highly praised in
Europe right off a horse get lost
this loading station for trees bears the
label sustainable forest management but
there's no way of checking whether this
is true moreover it's debatable whether
felling only diseased and damaged trees
doesn't destroy the fragile balance of
the ecosystem anyway the fact is once
the thin humus layer is gone nothing
else can grow
so in brasilia day can take six hours to
cover 300 kilometers in brazil doesn't
brazilian ship the hecklers these are
Brazilian conditions not European ones
yeah is there provide they are pushed em
this is the jungle which determines when
and how you get to a certain area you
can't be in a hurry here yeah that's my
kinda I laham roads bring prosperity
they say well then people in the remote
villages will soon have reason to
rejoice in the near future the
transoceanic ax will connect the
Brazilian Atlantic coast with the
Pacific coast in Peru an open road from
Sao Paulo to arequipa four thousand six
hundred kilometers for economic
development but environmentalists are
critical this is soft inside yeah this
is the season for forest fires here in
this region south of flights I think
maybe we should shoot here because you
can see this cloud of smoke really well
varam hysys this why do they say that
Brazil needs economic development
without realizing somehow that what we
already have the jungle is our greatest
wealth this was a grocery store
slash and burn cultivation is a vicious
circle for small farmers here they clear
a patch of forest but the soil is poor
in minerals so it's quickly exhausted
and the yields fall just as fast which
means they have to clear more
at the end of the first leg haces Brazil
a town on the border of Peru and Bolivia
elianas first stop is at the offices of
the Institute for the protection of
biodiversity in Brazil they should know
how to find her great-grandfather's old
rubber farm Oh me my cousin of Andhra
works for the environment agency in rio
branco and has sent me to you we want to
visit the s fella rubber farm Oh sitting
Gauss palea can't keep their the people
of the chico mendes nature reserve deal
with the rubber area the area in
question is named after the rubber
tapper and union leader chico mendes who
was assassinated in 1988 it covers
nearly a million hectares ish heavy big
katha Baku I got this map from people
here the Chico Mendes Institute in a sis
bro see you they told me how to get to
the river Yakov I'll go there tomorrow I
think it'll be exciting because the
journey is only now really getting
started perlon this realize affiliates
50f and
the roads are unpaved from here on in
and there's not likely to be much
oncoming traffic
he emerged if I want to stop because
it's so beautiful here I want to take a
look at it if you leave the scene I feel
that I'm close to the land where my
grandfather came into the world and my
great-grandmother who always said that
they used to like taking a bath in small
rivers like these and grab that's nice
it's such a nice feeling I love this
country isn't in business
the roots of the Fernandez family in
Brazil go back to the 17th century the
familia Metallica's I the family on my
mother's side came from Portugal
familiar dear they would use who had
converted to Christianity from your
dental minus my great-grandfather Jill
de rico Fernandez came to Accra from the
Northeast in 1870 sick that was the
first era of rubber production in Brazil
for her their culture give you know
embezzlement the colonization of the
Amazon basin is recent and the history
of the Fernandez family closely linked
with it le unnie sees her roots here and
not in Portugal after all her
great-grandfather was a Brazilian
the expedition to the farm of the rubber
baron jeweled erica fernandes comes to a
halt at the yaku river it will take at
least another five days by boat to get
there but le unnie is not disappointed
she's never gotten this close before if
I [ __ ] not my hair I know that I will
come here again I will make it at some
point I'll do it and then I'll go
downriver and see it lets see him about
it but I'm happy I know now that this is
the area my grandfather came from or per
hair combed the father of her beloved
grandfather was one of the first who set
out to make his fortune his is the story
of the rise and fall of the rubber
barons of the exploitation and
enslavement of the indigenous population
by its white colonial rulers even so if
against roids of Manuel I am very proud
of my great grandfather who managed to
come up the river without any modern
technology to start a new life oh so far
my noise leaving and so far that's part
of the history of the Amazon region and
part of my story this Amazon us get bids
no I'm time I negation I think it's fine
as well not really of course it also has
other side's a great many people died
with the coming of the white man their
vice not a nice part of the story
tension at a dagger sister I love the
zune beneath your I think that's why I
became an ethnologist so that i can make
amends and also support indigenous
projects understood sir
for years le unnie has regularly been
going on field research expeditions as a
cultural anthropologist at the
University of Bremen she loves the
challenge of travelling in remote areas
her field research this time is taking
her tomorrow show tomorrow go it can
only be reached by air taxi
soutien women it's so beautiful when
you're flying in a small plane over the
jungles it's like a sea of trees you
know a green carpet tippy
you
we start the approach to the remote town
the town was founded on the river
ammonia in the late 19th century as a
result of the rubber boom
Mary Shaw is a melting pot of indigenous
peoples and immigrants from Peru Bolivia
in southern Brazil the descendants of
rubber tappers and adventurers
what le unnie doesn't know is that a
visitor is waiting for her at the hotel
reception hello Jesse how are you is
everything okay everything's fine what a
surprise I didn't think we'd meet this
time I missed you a lot the most
important thing is that you're happy
isn't it
just seen that this is an Jacinta is a
very intelligent woman I would love her
to have exactly the same opportunities
as I had when I was young to use this
thirst for knowledge and to really
achieve something the small village of
oscillation worse don't make me finish
salad sometimes I think it's a pity
she's from this town because she can't
really develop here so interview concur
Jacinta is expecting her third child and
depends on her extended family for
support nevertheless she's optimistic
about the future and for now she's happy
her friend is here I Nathan wendaline
has a strong relationship with these
people in this forest that is very
important for me I know how much he
loves this region and her family her
ancestors have lived to you that's why
there's this connection my ancestors are
from here too so our relationship is
very close who knows maybe our
grandparents or great-grandparents also
met at some point to muscles up boy
those we love what you think 1000 year
we're on our way to see Donna glory Nia
donna kyrenia hey Donna Karenia how are
you everything's fine I'll take off my
shoes here it's nice to see you again
I'm back can you go to a picture with us
again and cook for us oh great Oh My
glory Donna kyrenia is my second mother
in our clay I have met a great many
people that I've really grown fond of
you sometimes I call them from Germany
and ask how they're doing and they're
pleased this assertion is it's nice to
work in a place where you have friends
it's practically my third family here
really this belt on
on the opposite side of the river lies
the euro inca atomy center for
environmental training its name means
knowledge of the jungle it was built by
the ash Anika with whom le unnie does
her field work they want to show it's
possible to protect the environment
while still being economically viable
respect for nature instead of logging
and yields but there's little funding
and everyone working here now does so
voluntarily there's no more money to pay
them but anyone even the non indigenous
population could benefit from this know
how the sustainable use of natural
resources such as bees and turtles
ileana collects donations to keep the
center running short of this I hope that
this Center will survive and that we can
manage to expand this model Sofia gross
it is not really considering how this
area is being developed the future is
obviously very difficult especially now
because they'll be drilling for oil and
gas here and that will of course
threaten the existence of Natural
Resources Juliana be drawn feared in
filling bastante are not work has
awesome here we see no way of stopping
it it's too late but we can try to keep
the damage to a minimum that is our new
challenge had asked for a little
traditional knowledge and Western
technology a symbiosis
the internet will be used to organize
the indigenous groups against
deforestation and pollution more
effectively solidarity between
indigenous tribes and environmentalists
has grown and they're now joining forces
even across national frontiers
it's 7am and the boat trip to the aschen
inca village will take at least 3 hours
le unnie wants to avoid the midday heat
a whole troop of young men is waiting to
help her load the luggage
keep them have we got everything Chico
it's all there can we board shown on
stag we can get on the boat
the journey is not without risk the
river is quite shallow and hidden tree
stumps can make the boat capsized and
sometimes there are also conflicts of
interest think a'somethin the Muslim
let's get throughout the Amazon region
it's sometimes very dangerous because
there are rivalries between groups there
are drug dealers once a group tried to
swamp our boat although that was only to
warn us not to come too close to them to
vine and as a result amina me tonight
what's he married a big lad you always
have to be accompanied by one of the
leaders or someone in the village who
knows the leaders family that's the only
way to come here to comas or monday you
can't just head off you need an escort
so yeah thank you le unnie quickly
greets the village elder Antonio Bianco
and his family and then gets straight to
work one of the things she brought in
the boat was sacks of rice
orgia
yeah about this the job of an
anthropologist is to watch and describe
how other cultures live you have to go
into the field to collect this data that
since that's what makes it so
interesting I have to pay very close
attention to how they live here what
they use how they use natural resources
and I must say this is the first time
that I have seen what they do with the
rice see the nice job I to come
the results will form part of Eliana's
post doctoral thesis it's topic is how
the aschen inka perceived the
environment the ethnologist wants to
arrange an interview with bebeto Bianco
he's a teacher and has also made
documentaries about the everyday life of
the shaniqua the first thing that
strikes Outsiders is the ocean Incas red
painted faces skip the initial there are
different types of makeup for
celebrations for hunting or for everyday
wear a pad in see it's Ryback when they
go to work they paint their faces with
anatom this red color to protect
themselves from the Sun that should see
if I that's honest mazya pintura ella no
es Oprah but I see the makeup isn't just
cosmetic they let the neighbor proti
here in a mimosa it should protect our
skin barely and shields us from evil
reportaje that squeezes Mountain Bay
neki body she got you painted in a
particular color then that drives evil
away 50 key I squeezed his mouth nay for
you have to feel at ease with it in
every possible way culturally
spiritually and as a whole person about
me you should feel at one with
everything and be in a good mood what
daughter's name or papito is basically
receptive to Eliana's questions but he
also finds them rather alien Mizuki elma
quizzer I realized that it's not part of
my culture with na your feet wet their
seas I'm even a little afraid that I
can't answer the questions or that my
answers don't correspond to what the
person wants to know Austin Osiecki doki
episode i meant Acadian do 19d but
there's also sense of becoming
acquainted
my census on g GC queen seon a premier
to me it's about understanding what the
person wants to know and also what
information i can provide carrying some
beer and my flat iron I once asked
achieve how important the stars were but
he misunderstood me and thought I wanted
to find out about the religious aspect
if our warranty that's a step too far
for them and I have to respect these
limits in a research group relationship
like this it's very important his own a
fossa could all feel bitsy hall the
first impression the village gives is
one of harmony
if I snore assist to me as a man I
remember when I first came here I really
felt I was in paradise it was an
indescribable feeling I felt so happy
that I was ashamed to be happy so far
away from my family I thought my god
Ellie Ani what's going on resistors make
them go a mile in Birken le unnie has
brought gifts yeah one is an almost
colonial gesture glass beads for the
natives have you heard this I heard that
a German started this custom i think it
was Carl fund and Steinem he brought
these beads here to Brazil and the
Indians like them so many tribes have
been using them to make jewelry ever
since that time yes really it's and is
it fair little schmuck tomorrow
especially the jewelry has now become a
source of income for the aschen Inca
they sell it in the city
eliana will spend the next few months
pushing ahead with her research the only
privacy she has is her own tent on this
night three hours boat ride away
jacinta's baby is born
so le unnie goes back down river for a
day she wants to see your friend and the
newborn baby oh how sweet a little girl
no have you chosen a name yet we're
looking for one we don't have one yet oh
how pretty do you have some hiccups baby
oh how cute you poor thing how you do I
ever be this easy on that guy sometimes
I was just dozing on the bed my daughter
was standing beside me as soon as I
dropped off the baby began to cry and
woke me up I opened my eyes looked at it
and thought oh yes there is someone
there and went back to sleep my daughter
took care of the baby sagem is yes
seguin buff on she assumed to that it
would be a boy but then a girl arrived
doc I'm meet you but that's nice that's
a nice surprise I'm so pleased this is
ephraim now we know they've called the
baby felicia the happy one
back in a picture bingo spires and swish
and evade I'm torn between these three
worlds it's not easy as i have several
homes is that even possible then dad
says fun I don't know but the places
where I feel at home yes I've got three
places where I feel at home meanness are
clay and Germany as well I'm a kind of
ethnological gypsy ha ha ha ha
they'll be let's all dance baby dance
blue tears some assembly dunno serene